good morning Hank it's Tuesday sorry I
needed him for white balancing so Hank I
really liked your video a couple weeks
ago about the ownership of ideas and I
agree with you that current copyright
law is a hot slice of crazy but hey
people and ideas needs some kind of
copyright protection because otherwise
like CBS could come along and take all
the blog Brothers videos and just put
them on their network and call the show
two brothers slowly age and I would hate
that because one my face was not
designed for like forty two inch HD
televisions and two CBS would make all
of this money and I would get nothing
okay so for example Hank let's say that
you design this generally what happens
is that if I want to make a t-shirt out
of that design i buy the design from you
let's say I pay $100 so I buy the design
and now I own it I make a t-shirt and if
the t-shirt is a failure you have your
$100 and if it is a wild success that
generates millions of t-shirts you have
your $100 this has always struck me as
unfair because yes I made the t-shirt
and distribute it and whatnot but it's
still your design so you should still
kind of own it and this is why dftba
records is now focused on royalties for
nerdfighter designers like every time
you buy a pizza John shirt I split the
royalties with Valerie twenty seven
seventy six who designed it it's her
design but it's my face and mustache so
we go halfsies that's relatively simple
this is very complicated
so a few weeks ago I'm scrolling through
the tiffy OS tag on tumblr as I do and I
come across this and I'm like that is a
fantastic poster and I want it to be on
my wall
so I reblogged it and then I sent a
tumblr user and asked saying like we
should do this on dftba records it'll be
so fun and then she wrote me back and
she was like yeah I didn't design that
and I don't know who did so that I asked
um where does anyone know who designed
this and a 16 year old Filipino
nerdfighter named Nika wrote in and said
yes it was me and I was like great all
of our problems are solved and then Nika
was like yeah I made this painting and
then someone turned it into a poster and
I was like okay who is the someone at
Nika was like I have no idea so then for
a couple weeks Nick and I were doing
some like hardcore Sherlock style
detective work on tumblr and then
finally we found the person who adapted
the painting into a poster it was
another 16 year old nerdfighter this one
living in Norway named a shield a shil
when I asked her how to pronounce her
name she said given you're in Erbil
to pronounce the Swedish title of your
book I don't think you can do it which
is just not fair because I'm excellent
at pronouncing forever Senora explorer
jog god I love this cover I'm just gonna
let Google Translate do it will see me
right so she made the poster so I had to
summarize I wrote a book in the United
States which inspired a reader of mine
in the Philippines to make a painting
which in turn inspired another reader of
mine in Norway to make a poster hake
international copyright law just isn't
ready for that kind of thing also
vitally neither Nica nor myself gave
permission to I'm just gonna call her
Ashley neither of us gave permission to
Ashley to make the poster but we both
love the poster so the three of us on
three different continents came to a
royalty agreement then we paid the guy
who designed the font and now at last it
is a poster that is available for
pre-order now at dftba.com I will sign
the first however many are pre-ordered I
think we need better copyright law but
in the meantime we have to try to do
well by each other and by each other's
ideas for me that means welcoming and
encouraging fanfiction and music or art
inspired by my books so Hank as you
pointed out in your video when money
enters the picture things change like I
would be super annoyed if CBS made an
adaptation of The Fault in Our Stars
without my permission but I'm very happy
when people like adapt scenes from the
book in YouTube videos even if those
videos have ads on them and we really
don't have a good way of defining the
difference between nerdfighters making
something on YouTube and Viacom making
something on CBS unless and until the
mess of copyright gets untangled and the
laws get better we're going to have to
police ourselves but the good news is
that the Internet is actually pretty
good at - take I think the most
important things are that the Internet
continues to be vigilant which don't
worry it will that we try to be fair to
each other and that we never let
copyright law make us afraid to create
because that is the opposite of what
it's supposed to do Hank I'll see you on
Friday